slightly more responsible person and
perhaps I was many years ago and let's
just think um and I think you know now
I'm being a bit repetitive I just don't
want to waste and waste the position I'm
in so and it would be easier or almost
just to say you know that you know it's
a school holiday time and you know I
must you know and I'm just going to go
after the beach etc etc well actually
when the kids were growing up you know i
did i did make sure ice plant found the
time for the power move now the kids
have grown up and you know I can make
sure I find the time to and to say yes
to people who ask me to do things which
you know which will make a real
difference in the world and that's what
I plan to do